e attacca attacca attacca chi è cosa
carina è la tt ragazze benvenuto che
sono video sono farisei che ci siamo
dati sugli under simulator di 20 ragazzi
il videogame dove impersona una ragazza
ragazza e che dio mi sembri cazzo sei un
figo narrazione è perfetto questo testo
il taglio di capelli più sexy che abbia
mai visto
ed è proprio il tipo del quale mi sono
innamorata e che cazzo è sembra un
alieno va beh niente ragazzi questo è il
mio senpai sarebbe mio moroso
io sono una strana hoc a lui è un cesso
ambulante però la chimica così così e
morpheus di matrix è uguale lui aveva
certo ma perché tanto non si vede
credo ok sono veramente una [ __ ] devo
capire un attimo dov'è il mio stand by
se poi sei tu oh mio dio mio livello è
il mio morpheus ragazzi e lui sembrare
normale devo sembrare normale c'è una
pizza che ti stai volando chi dopo che i
ragazzi la mia prima missione uccidere
quella [ __ ] attenta ha tentato di
approcciare col mio uomo
no no no no no zia fammi capire amica
aprire il senso voglio capirlo
io ho sempre desiderato andare a scuola
con un frappé con un ghiacciolo
all'anice perché sono al passo coi tempi
ragazzi con la moda moderna cioè che
posso fare colpo su di lui con queste
mutande in faccia sono sicuro che adesso
non e non interessa perché vi poi parte
stronzi è la madonna dai ragazzi
seriamente tutti questi tentativi di
diventare come chiara biasi porca eva
però la posso parlarti per un attimo mi
complimento con te sei molto carina oggi
la dieta va seguita in un certo modo
perché per cortesia per quello che mi
spiega come ho fatto a fare sta roba
perché non cup non l'ho capito manco io
cioè tu vuoi dirmi che io posso
diventare una super sayan madonna ponte
modalità hanno aggiunto slang dermot
four che va più figo no vabbè vabbè
ragazzi ami bravi avete avete la stima
della vita fermi tutti poco più che cosa
non va in mezzo
vuoi vedere un qualche cosa più
spaventoso di mezzi a guarda il mio
telefono guarda che merda ragazzi non do
nell'occhio vero non sembra che sia
cattivo per carità perché te ne stai a
camminare in giro così hai qualche
problema per caso tu che cazzo guardi
che che cammino sull'aria è la cosa più
bella della sovrana ferma che non ci
passi non ci passi dove sempre ma se poi
si è cagato talmente tanto addosso che
gli son rimasti solo gli occhiali disse
ma sono curioso di vedere che mi che
hanno aggiunto prima vedere le altre
robe
se poi guardare devo farti una foto ma
non posso cazzo non posso il cappello
mio strisce devo farle foto a caso
perché se uno dei full mouse che cosa
diventa un haider era invece non ti sto
guardando male voglio solo strappare il
cranio io ho una scopa a chi pulisco
questo cazzo di giardino prima che tu ci
passi è che contento europa tenta la
scopa attenta lazio ecco non riesce
neanche a sfruttarla sei troppo magra
zia ok stavo scherzando è un problema
comune questo banco in tre con la scopa
è un ostacolo della vita ragazzi ho
scoperto come non andare a scuola basta
mettere una scopa all'entrata non entra
nessuno da adesso in avanti nelle
giustificazioni scolastiche scrivete
tutti c'era una scopa là davanti alla
porta è che siete giustificato a sono
una fata che fa le foto posso guardarmi
la pasta e ragazzi le fatine lo araba 9
lo zio che darà fano sono una falsa
timida ascoltami è sempre non mi caga di
striscio attiva se facciamo una cosa a
tre non è che voglio essere stalker e
per carità e che voglio proprio essere
stalker 15 giro intorno a non cambiare
direzione che tanto ti trovo lo stesso
se poi guardami guardami guarda che bel
colpo e tutto tu sai dovete limpido sono
mica chi era lei la [ __ ] che guardava
prima sempre lo ridà fruttare
pensavo che coi tuoi occhiali da sole
non vedessi un cazzo no no no se
sparisci sempre perché ti cade addosso
il k modo a donkey kong li ka fai più
schifo di prima sempre guarda ora come
anti social siamo tutti che gli occhi
così devo dire oddio assomiglia troppo
semplice sono diventata anch'io se vai
sono pelata come te guarda siamo uguali
siamo uguali fondo e forse è capirai
anche tu senpai che sono gioca anch'io
amami santo iddio dai zio amami hicks
mode manca l'ultima poi c'è l'attacco
dei giganti ok se non sarà fatta in poi
me la faccio io
ma allora sei proprio gay forte mi sto
innamorando sempre di più e tutti i file
e domande sulla vita cazzo sei lopardi
ultima trasforma sia onda provare quella
di titan che abbiamo già provato la
titan mouse che la più bella sono ecco
fa anche nudi perché non basta gica pure
nudi perché giganti su tutti nudi tra
madonna
marcatori ma non mi cagare costa pelata
di lotta mamma si è incazzata quando ti
sei tagliato i capelli ma quando cazzo
ti sbagli
ragazzi questa è la modalità che in
assoluto preferisco li sto gioco non so
perché la tettona sta parlando al
telefono è il momento giusto per un
assassinio ho bisogno di un di un
qualcosa che in via poco nell'occhio
perfetto simpa i nomi vedrà mai frutta
[ __ ] vedeva tanto non si vede che c'è
del sangue per carità la trascina non
lascio traccia affaccio rogazzo the
tieni gli occhiali da sole anche il
mattino c'è qualcuno ti chiede se è
svenuta perchè giocato troppo a basket
uno sport di savoca tso ciao ragazze ho
nel sangue addosso ma è il mio maestro
perché è normale ragazzi sanno
alessandra dosso potrebbe essere quello
e sangue ciao ragazzi nice one in
cosplay non è che questo non è colonne e
sangue di maestro no no non è sangue di
mestre 1 sterno state sbagliando dai
ragazzi cioè le forbici due anni dove
uccidere un gigante con le forbici
il mio sogno eccolo da attacca attacca
attacca
ecco è morto chi mi ha visto ammazzare
tutti ammazzati tutti fatti tre stato
nessuno che tiene il suo di vero oddio
oddio c'è la gente che si sta guardando
in giro perché vedono i corpi morti però
non capiscono chi è stato che per
spaventato a morte poverino senta prof
per cortesia posto uccidere anche la
prof seriamente non ci credo come casa a
farlo
non ci posso credere mai qualche avati a
che pro complimenti non pensavo fosse
così cazzuta la mia prof seriamente cioè
a me
la mia era peggio quando non facevo i
compiti ma molto peggio
tutti ragazzi ho provato tutte le mode
provato anche a vedere come sempre
reagiva alle mie amante che scena
raccapricciante lega guarda sempre ti ho
fatto un regalo è una donna morta
puoi giocarci a briscola importante era
che tutti si perché sono rose lander mac
tu sei degli occhiali e non permetta
degli occhiali di mancarmi di rispetto
ragazzi se il pai non va caricato di
striscio pazienza sarà per la prossima
volta
non riesco a prendere un videogioco
seriamente non ce la posso fare spero
che mi devi sempre 100 ragazzi cosa che
mi è piaciuta soprattutto è un mi piace
fatemi sapere qual è la vostra moto
preferita di questo video perché alla
mia credo sia splendere in assoluto
perché è troppo bella cosa sente se vi è
piaciuta certamente mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook con il videoton
estinzione